le truc avec Todd, c'est qu'il a fait un
film sur l'amour et le désir et
à quel point l'amour est dangereux, c'est juste une
histoire d'amour
oui, c'est entre deux femmes mais
j'espère qu'un jour nous n'aurons plus
besoin d'en parler.  Ce
sera juste normal,
la chose à laquelle j'ai répondu quand j'ai
lu le livre et le scénario, c'est
à quel point c'était incroyablement universel et à quel
point cela me rappelait d'être à la place de Reza
tomber amoureux de quelqu'un sans
savoir où j'en étais sans savoir  ce qu'ils
ont ressenti en retour, vous savez, c'est un
sentiment très très universel quand j'ai lu Le
prix du sel, le roman sur lequel Carol
est basé par Patricia Highsmith, la
relation intense, presque claustrophobe, de cette subjectivité
enfermée dans l'esprit purulent de Torres
m'en a dit long  l'expérience de
tomber amoureux les distorsions du fait de
tomber amoureux et l'isolement que
nous ressentons souvent au tout début de
l'amour vous savez et la façon dont nous fabriquons
et construisons tout ce que vous connaissez toutes
sortes de scénarios et de fantasmes et des
affrontements potentiels avec  notre objet de
désir et, curieusement, c'est
exactement ainsi qu'elle traite l'esprit criminel
dans ses romans policiers et donc le crime et l'
amour sont liés d'une manière très spécifique,
ce qui m'intéressait vraiment. Le
livre est étrange car il ressemble beaucoup à
un Highsmith Ian.  ce n'est pas un
thriller mais il contient des éléments d'étrange
tristesse et de mélancolie et Carol est
plutôt dépressive mais ce qui est
merveilleux c'est qu'il explore
ce sentiment de simplement tomber amoureux
c'est bien sûr une histoire d'amour ou un
examen de la façon dont un amour peut  développer
mais il a aussi le
ton habituel de menace sous-jacente de Highsmith Ian, équilibrer le
ton est une chose délicate dans
les adaptations de Highsmith, il a un
point de vue extérieur mais il a un
cœur tellement incroyable et quand il a appelé
et dit qu'il avait lu le script  et
il adorerait vraiment le faire,
j'ai bien sûr supposé que vous savez qu'il
est né loin du paradis, il comprend
l'époque où ce sera une
sorte d'expérience semblable à un bijou au cirque Douglas, mais quand
il a commencé à me montrer toutes les références
de  toutes ces femmes photographes qui
travaillaient dans les années 50, son travail
n'a jamais été réalisé de leur vivant Vivian le
mien par exemple son travail je ne
connaissais pas ses références ses
références visuelles étaient si inattendues tout ce
sens de New York et des années 50 dans ton
reflet  Je sais que le sentiment d'une
femme n'a été vu que dans le reflet
des hommes, qu'elle y était connectée,
le genre de méta-vision pour le film,
c'était vraiment excitant pour eux, c'est la
chose extraordinaire à propos de Todd, c'est qu'il est
capable d'apporter le point de vue d'un étranger.
le courant dominant du cinéma donc
il est, euh, il a un tel, il a en quelque sorte
un pied dans les deux camps et en travaillant avec
lui, on a immédiatement l'impression qu'il travaille sur
une envie d'être à grande échelle, une grande vision,
mais il a quand même  cette
mentalité de cinéaste indépendant indien qui, pour avoir l'
impression de créer
quelque chose de nouveau et de frais, est vraiment
excitant de travailler dans tous les
départements du cinéma, ils sont tous
importants, tout le travail créatif nécessaire
à la réalisation d'un film est si essentiel
cela va tellement au-delà de ce que fait le réalisateur
et vous devez donc vraiment faire confiance,
respecter et écouter tous vos
partenaires que vous connaissez et c'est peut-être
quelque chose d'aussi simple que cela que vous vous
sentez soutenu par le fait qu'il y a une fondation
sous eux pour leur donner la liberté
de  faire ce que je fais
de mieux, je veux créer un monde dans lequel je
pense que les personnages auraient vécu
et qui, selon les acteurs, les aide à
comprendre leurs personnages. C'étaient donc
deux personnages très différents, ils
viennent de différentes classes économiques et de
différentes classes socio-économiques.
et il y a différents moments
dans leur vie, Carol a atteint un point
en elle, elle traverse une
crise de la quarantaine et elle a atteint un point dans sa
vie où elle a fait beaucoup de choses et mais
elle n'est pas heureuse et Torres ne sait pas
ce qu'elle veut faire  pourtant, il y a un
personnage très jeune et pas seulement un âge
mais dans sa position dans la vie
et un personnage très plus âgé et l'un
a beaucoup d'argent et l'autre n'en a pas, donc
vous savez que c'était un contraste, c'est des
mondes contrastés  et c'est très
intéressant de jouer avec
des mondes contrastés, ce n'est pas quelque chose sur lequel nous avons retravaillé,
tout était dans le scénario,
toutes ces nuances, j'aimerais pouvoir m'en
attribuer le mérite, mais tout était
là dans l'écriture et non dans le look.
tes yeux, c'est quelque chose de différent, eh
bien, je veux dire, quand tu regardes
Kate, tu n'as tout simplement pas de cigarettes, il y
a très peu d'actrices qui peuvent jouer
le protagoniste et la fille de Dragon
Tattoo, puis jouer cette sorte de
culte Audrey Hepburn esque de Muir
exposée  le personnage brut qu'est Torres, je
veux dire, elle a un goût si impeccable,
incroyablement intelligent, très
pragmatique et travailleur dans la façon dont
elle aborde un rôle, mais elle est intrépide
et a une gamme extraordinaire, vous
savez, j'ai adoré travailler avec elle et j'étais
vraiment très excité.  Quand Todd a dit
qu'elle allait jouer le rôle,
permettez-moi de poser une question idiote, mais qu'est-ce que
ça fait d'être sur la persévérance du réalisateur,
c'est un peu écrasant. Je dois
dire que cela fait de nombreuses années et regardez qui je
vais partager le tapis rouge.
J'étais très nerveux, non, je courais avec
parce que j'avais beaucoup de café et je
pense que je ne sais pas si j'ai déjà été
ici avec la compétition de tournage et il
y a une texture légèrement différente
autour, vous savez, j'ai été  ici avec
des films très différents mais tout le monde
impliqué dans Carroll, c'était un vrai travail
d'amour et que le scénario
existait depuis 15 ans et et donc je suis
vraiment fier d'avoir été mon partenaire et d'
avoir éclaté et d'en avoir fait partie  de l'
équipe de production d'orioles qui l'a mis sur pied,
vous savez que cela semble très important et
spécial pour tous ceux qui participent à sa
fabrication. Je veux dire, je pense que nous sommes encore
très coincés dans le passé et tout
comme Kate le disait plus tôt, il y a 70
pays qui sont encore  illégal, c'est
choquant et frustrant, mais nous avons aussi le
sentiment que nous avons fait des progrès et nous
devrions nous ne devrions pas simplement rejeter ces
progrès, mais il reste encore beaucoup de
progrès à faire.
Je pense qu'il serait insensé de ne pas le faire.
reconnaître les progrès que nous avons réalisés, la
vitesse à laquelle la société évolue sous nos
yeux sur ces choses, je veux dire,
je n'aurais jamais imaginé
qu'apparemment, il y a un sondage aux
États-Unis qui dit que plus d'Américains
voteraient pour un président gay que pour un président gay.
Président évangélique chrétien, c'est un
changement qui n'a pu être vrai qu'au cours des
5 à 10 dernières années, vous savez, c'est
rapide pour la plupart des sociétés, donc pendant un certain temps, tout
cela est vrai, évidemment quelque chose est une
chose oui, évidemment, ce n'est pas vrai
partout dans le monde,
c'est un  une histoire d'amour bien sûr et vous
savez, je pense que sa
portée est beaucoup plus large que le fait d'être une
expérience de niche, mais je pense que ce qui rend une expérience
encore dangereuse, peut-être inhabituelle, de
nos jours, c'est l'amour entre
deux terres,
je suppose que nous  J'ai fait des tonnes de
progrès, alors maintenant on peut se marier et
avec un seul souhait et nous sommes à Los Angeles
ou New York ou Londres ou Paris et ce
sont des endroits assez sophistiqués et privilégiés
ou ils peuvent l'être, mais si nous
parcourons probablement une centaine de kilomètres  au nord, nous
rencontrerons des communautés où nous ne sommes pas
les bienvenus et nous ne serons peut-être pas tués
pour cela, c'est peut-être le progrès que nous avons
fait, mais chaque jour, vous lisez des histoires
sur les personnes transgenres gays et lesbiennes qui
souffrent vraiment, pensez-vous qu'un
film comme Carol  peut aider de cette manière
peut aider à changer le genre d'être une sorte
d'aide, j'espère, je veux dire, dans la mesure où les films
pourront un jour aider à changer quelque chose, ce que j'espère, c'est
qu'il
impressionnera même deux ou trois
jeunes sur la nécessité d'un
identité honnête, donc j'espère que le film aidera de
cette façon,
bien sûr, le genre des femmes, le fait
que les deux femmes sont tombées
amoureuses et dans les années 1950, quand un tel amour était
bien, si c'était des hommes, il serait considéré comme
criminel mais ce n'était pas le cas.  même
assez digne d'être qualifié de criminel, c'était juste une
sorte d'extension et d'hystérie féminine,
vous savez, c'est vraiment important mais je
pense que le film est plus que ça et moi
et donc je pense que c'est euh vous réalisez que
vous avez vu des gens tomber
amoureux du  première fois et tous les
dangers l'aspect humain de ce qui je
pense est vraiment puissant et je pense
que c'est ce qui fait que le film oserais dire
important peut-être mais sans importance on dirait que ce n'est
pas il n'y a aucun plaisir
à le voir je pense qu'on se laisse emporter
par l'histoire d'amour que
tu